This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数占百分之二。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收看我的播客《2%》。在这个充满现代怪异世界的时代，我将为您剖析坚韧不拔的意志、健康体魄以及培养适应力的秘诀。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一番磨难，你将会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。请收听《2%》。搜索数字“2%”，即可在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《Look Back At It》播客。那是在1979年，对我来说是一个意义重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都感觉不够安全而无法展开的坦诚对话，但在这里，你将与一位深谙此道的专业持证心理咨询师进行交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力。你就必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方收听《艰难抉择》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对……
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, another topic as we break down the psychology of our 20s.
对我们的心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听我们的又一期节目，探讨我们剖析二十岁心理的又一个话题。
Before we get into it, I just want to say that this topic was a suggestion from one of our wonderful listeners. And I saw her message and I could not believe that we hadn't spoken. about it before because it is just that universal. So thank you to Abby in California for your incredible suggestion and inspiration. If you have a topic that you want me to cover something going on in your life or that you see in the world that you wish you had a
在深入探讨之前，我只想说，这个话题是由我们一位可爱的听众建议的。当我看到她的留言时，我简直不敢相信我们以前竟然没有谈论过。关于它，因为它是如此具有普遍性。所以，非常感谢加利福尼亚州的艾比，感谢你的绝佳建议和灵感。如果你有一个希望我报道的话题，或者你生活中正在发生的事情，或者你在世界上看到的，你希望你有一个……
psychological explanation for, please feel free to DM me on Instagram at that psychology podcast. I would love to hear from you and whatever is on your mind. But let's get back into it and talk about our topic today, which is why do we replay conversations? This happens to me all of the time, almost at, I would say, an unimaginable level, and not just in the moments after the conversation or interaction, but for days afterwards. And most of the time, the conversations I am replaying are not necessarily negative or awkward or uncomfortable in the moment, I just can't shake this like need to give myself a continuous play by play. Searching for things I may have said that were weird or embarrassing what the other person
关于它的心理学解释，请随时在Instagram上私信我，账号是That Psychology Podcast。我很乐意听到你的声音以及你心中的任何想法。但让我们回到正题，聊聊我们今天的话题，那就是我们为什么会反复回想对话？这种事一直都在发生在我身上，几乎可以说达到了难以想象的程度，而且不仅是在对话或互动刚结束的那一刻，而是在接下来的好几天里。而且大多数时候，我反复回想的对话在当时并不一定是负面的、尴尬的或令人不舒服的，我只是无法摆脱这种需要给自己不断进行实况解说的冲动。寻找我可能说过的奇怪或尴尬的话，以及对方……
may have thought of me examining every very small, minute detail. Maybe you're in the same boat. You relate to this description. You are also repeatedly thinking over everything, you know, your boss may have said at that last meeting or that conversation you have with a stranger. at a house party, late night chats with your partner, every small interaction with an acquaintance on the street where you barely said a few words. It can be so small, insignificant even, but you're left thinking, was that strange? Was that awkward? What is their perception of me after that? Perhaps you're
可能对我的看法，审视每一个非常微小、细致的细节。也许你也处于同样的境况。你对这种描述感同身受。你也一直在反复琢磨你所知道的一切，比如你的老板在上次会议上可能说过的话，或者你和一个陌生人的对话。在家庭聚派对上，与伴侣深夜聊天，与街上熟人的每一次微小互动，你甚至几乎没说几句话。它可以是如此微不足道，甚至微不足道，但你却忍不住去想，那很奇怪吗？那很尴尬吗？在那之后，他们对我的看法是什么？也许你在……
thinking back to that. One thing you said that maybe was a little bit weird, and you're magnifying it as if it was the only thing said rather than in the context of a lot of other things and you're just wishing that you could take it back or sometimes we wish that we'd pushed deeper we'd said more I think that is especially the case when we're having conversations about things that are inherently vulnerable like mental health where in the moment we're not quite sure what to say but afterwards we think of everything we wished we had said if you are someone in your and you haven't experienced that, I think you may be the anomaly because it's a feeling that emerges from so many secondary emotional experiences that we're having in this decade,
回想那件事。你说的第一句话可能有点奇怪，你把它放大得好像那是唯一说出的话，而不是放在很多其他事情的背景下，你只是希望你能收回它，或者有时我们希望我们能挖掘得更深，说得更多。我认为当我们进行关于像心理健康这样本质上脆弱的事情的对话时，情况尤其如此，在当时我们并不太确定该说些什么，但事后我们会想起所有我们希望自己说过的话。如果你是这样一个生活在其中的人，而你却没有经历过，我想你可能是一个特例，因为这种感觉源于我们在这一十年中经历的如此多的次要情感体验，
feeling awkward, feeling strange in our own skin, feeling insecure and inadequate, trying to figure out how to manage nuanced and complicated emotions, not just other people's emotions as well, but our own. And it's not all about the conversation. In fact, I think it really is about the contents of the conversation that we're worried about. It is the personal weight that we place on other people's perceptions and opinions of us. It stems from our very deep desire to be accepted. So we scan our memories for anything that indicates that this person maybe didn't like us, or thinks of us in a way that is not aligned with the version of us that we want people to see, who we want people to think that we are.
感到尴尬，在自己的皮肤里感到陌生，感到不安全和不胜任，试图弄清楚如何处理微妙而复杂的情绪，不仅是别人的情绪，还有我们自己的情绪。这一切并不全是关于对话。事实上，我认为这真的关乎我们所担忧的对话内容。这是我们对别人对我们的看法和意见赋予的个人分量。它源于我们被接受的极度渴望。因此，我们扫描我们的记忆，寻找任何表明这个人可能不喜欢我们的迹象，或者以一种与我们希望人们看到的版本不一致的方式看待我们，也就是我们希望人们认为我们是的人。
I think this occurs for a few reasons. Number one is because our brains are not relegating those unimportant conversations and forgetting about them as we probably should. Our brains are holding them at the same level of priority as more important. situations or interactions. So it causes this confusion between what is actually worth us remembering and what is not. When we replay conversations, what we're really experiencing is rumination. Rumination involves repetitive thinking or dwelling on past experiences and events, particularly the negative aspects, sometimes like we said for weeks, even months afterwards.
我认为这发生的原因有几个。第一是因为我们的大脑没有像我们可能应该做的那样，将那些不重要的对话搁置一边并将它们忘掉。我们的大脑把它们和更重要的事件放在同等优先的地位。情况或互动。因此，这就造成了什么真正值得我们记住、什么不值得我们记住之间的混淆。当我们重播对话时，我们真正经历的是反刍。反刍涉及重复思考或沉浸在过去的经验和事件中，特别是消极的方面，有时正如我们所说，持续数周甚至数月。
how I describe it is that our brains are stuck in this loop or mental maze that we can't break out of, even when we want to. This preoccupation with some small, probably negligible social interaction takes up so much space in our mind. When we are replaying conversations, we are experiencing two distinct types of this rumination pattern. Firstly, we have post-event processing. which is the pervasive detailed reviewing of socially failed or embarrassing activities or situations
我是这样描述的：我们的大脑陷入了这种循环或心理迷宫，即使我们想打破它也无法摆脱。这种对一些小的、可能微不足道的社交互动的全神贯注，占据了我们大脑中如此多的空间。当我们回放对话时，我们正在经历这种反刍模式的两种截然不同的类型。首先，我们有事后处理。这是对社交失败或尴尬活动或情况的无孔不入的详细回顾。
that are perceived even more negatively in hindsight than they actually were because of our anxiety, because of the kind of spotlight that we put on them. And secondly is stress reactive rumination. So this involves constantly thinking about situations that may be caused, caused stress or will cause stress in the future as a way to dull their importance and look for a solution to prepare for things that might arise, might not. It's almost like, you know, catastrophizing the future by looking at the past. So when I say that rumination can dull the importance of conversations or the things we may have said wrong, this may seem counterintuitive,
由于我们的焦虑，由于我们对它们投入的聚光灯，它们在后见之明中被认为比实际情况更具负面性。其次是压力反应性反刍。因此，这涉及不断思考可能引起、已经引起压力或将在未来引起压力的情境，以此来淡化它们的重要性并寻找解决方案，为可能出现或可能不会出现的事情做准备。这几乎就像是通过回顾过去来灾难化未来。所以，当我说反刍可以淡化对话或我们可能说错的话的重要性时，这似乎有违直觉，
but really, rumination exists as a way to self-soothe or emotionally regulate, even if it's maladaptive, by turning over a memory or a conversation in our head over and over again. It's like pushing on a fresh bruise, right? It hurts, but it also feels less painful the more we do it because we're desensitizing ourselves. The metaphor I always give is that rumination does to our memories, as the ocean kind of does to a pebble. With every moment we spend thinking about it, we slowly smooth it out.
但实际上，反刍的存在是为了自我安慰或调节情绪，即使它是适应不良的，通过在脑海中一遍又一遍地翻转记忆或对话。这就像按压一个新鲜的淤青，对吧？它很痛，但我们做得越多，感觉就越不那么痛，因为我们在让自己脱敏。我经常给出的比喻是，反刍对我们的记忆就像海洋对鹅卵石的作用一样。随着我们花时间思考它的每一个时刻，我们慢慢地把它抹平。
We slowly feel more comfortable with our thoughts or reflections of what we said. We make ourselves more comfortable with our discomfort the same way that the ocean kind of smooths out or the crevices on a rock. Some studies also suggest that rumination provides us with an illusion of control. So if we think about that interaction more and more, we feel like we have more control over the event because we've spent so much time thinking about it. Right? It's kind of the same with overthinking.
我们慢慢地对自己的想法或对我们所说的话的反思感到更舒服。我们让我们自己对自己的不适感到更加舒适，就像海洋把岩石上的裂缝抹平一样。一些研究还表明，反刍给我们带来了控制的错觉。因此，如果我们越来越多地考虑这种互动，我们会觉得自己对事件有更多的控制权，因为我们花了这么多的时间去思考它。对吧？这有点像过度思考。
So when you worry about something you mull it over, you're kind of trying to prepare for if this person comes back and says to you, hey, that was really weird. Why did you say that? And it's strangely satisfying to us because it allows us to feel like we can kind of predict that this might, happen, we're in some way in control, prepared for what's coming by forcing ourselves to replay it again and again and again. And of course, that's not true. Unfortunately, you know, the conversation is in the past. There's nothing we can do to change it. Thinking about it more is not going to change what someone else's perception of us is in the moment. But rehashing future conversations based on
所以当你担心某件事并仔细琢磨时，你其实是在试图为这种情况做准备：如果这个人回来对你说，嘿，那真的很奇怪。你为什么这么说？这让我们感到奇怪的满意，因为它让我们觉得我们可以某种程度上预测这可能会发生，我们在某种程度上掌控了局面，通过强迫自己一遍又一遍地重播它来为即将发生的事情做好准备。当然，事实并非如此。不幸的是，你知道，对话已经成为过去。我们做任何事都无法改变它。多想一想并不会改变别人此刻对我们的看法。但基于……重新审视未来的对话
past experiences is another way that we keep ourselves stuck in these memories. And I think it evolves as a way for us to obviously prepare for how we want to change our behavior, what we want to say in the future. If we can identify what went wrong in that interaction that's causing us embarrassment, we can prevent it from occurring again. So we protect ourselves from the potential future opportunities to feel cringe or to feel bad about ourselves. But that can also morph into anticipatory anxiety where when we are like constantly trying to prepare what we might say in a conversation, how we're going to guide the conversation, we're making like a mental checklist of topics, we actually become really fearful of these imagined scenarios where we might not be as
过去的经历是我们让自己深陷这些记忆中的另一种方式。我认为它演变成了一种方式，显然是为了让我们准备好如何改变我们的行为，我们在未来想说的话。如果我们能找出导致我们尴尬的那次互动中出了什么问题，我们就能防止它再次发生。因此，我们保护自己免受未来可能感到畏缩或对自已感到不好的潜在机会的影响。但这也会演变成预期焦虑，当我们就像不断试图准备我们在对话中可能说的话，我们将如何引导对话，我们正在制作一个话题的心单，我们实际上对这些想象中的场景感到非常恐惧，在这些场景中我们可能没有像
socially adept as we would like to be. And these scenarios, they only exist in our heads, but they are causing us really quite tangible and real fear. I think in those moments, we have to remind ourselves why we care. Why does this person's opinion matter so much that we are taking, allowing it to take up so much of our limited cognitive capacity, right? Is their opinion going to do us physical harm? Is it going to stop the real people? our life from loving us? Is it going to make you any less happy? That is a big question. Is it going to reduce your enjoyment of life? Probably not unless you put emphasis on it, unless you decide to think about it. Their thoughts are neither our problem or our business. Honestly, who cares if you came off weird?
我们希望的那样精通社交。这些场景只存在于我们的脑海中，但它们确实给我们带来了切实且真实的恐惧。我认为在那些时刻，我们必须提醒自己为什么我们在乎。为什么这个人的意见如此重要，以至于我们正在占用、允许它占用我们如此有限的认知能力，对吧？他们的意见会对我们造成身体伤害吗？它会阻止现实中的人吗？我们的生活爱我们吗？它会让你减少快乐吗？这是一个大问题。它会减少你对生活的享受吗？可能不会，除非你强调它，除非你决定去想它。他们的想法既不是我们的问题，也不是我们的事。老实说，如果你表现得很奇怪，谁会在乎呢？
I say that is so much more authentic than the people who are preoccupied with impressing other people at their own expense. And it really doesn't matter all that much. We talk to thousands of people across a year. Not all of those conversations are going to be like incredible. We're not always going to say the perfect thing. We're always going to have regrets. We cannot hold on to those because there's just so many of them that we would have to keep locked up in our brain. Also as an important reminder, people's memories are a lot shorter than we think, and they are normally way too focused on themselves to be critically analyzing our behavior. But that inherent need to care, that need to overthink small moments, comes from that social, very intuitive social side of us
我说，这比那些全神贯注于以牺牲自己为代价去给别人留下深刻印象的人要真实得多。而且这其实并没有那么重要。我们一年要和数千人对话。并非所有这些对话都是不可思议的。我们并不总是能说出最完美的话。我们总会有遗憾。我们不能紧抓着这些不放，因为有太多这样的事情需要我们锁在脑海里。另外需要提醒的是，人们的记忆比我们想象的要短得多，他们通常太关注自己，以至于无法批判性地分析我们的行为。但那种内在的在乎需求，那种过度思考小时刻的需求，来自于那个社会的、非常直观的社交一面，它渴望亲密并害怕疏离或社会排斥。
that craves closeness and fears alienation or social exclusion. To explain this, Let's talk about this idea of rejection sensitivity. For those of us who are chronic overthinkers and replayers, when it comes to our social interactions, sometimes it can come down to actually something deeper that's going on in our brain. Rejection sensitivity, dysphoria, and our old favorite social anxiety. So rejection, sensitivity, dysphoria, this relates to our inability to regulate our emotional, responses to perceived rejection, not actual rejection, but our own interpretation of a situation. For example, if someone kind of slightly turns away from you or leaves to go to the bathroom
为了解释这一点，让我们来谈谈拒绝敏感性的这个概念。对于我们这些习惯性过度思考和反复回放的人来说，当谈到我们的社交互动时，有时它可能归结为我们大脑中正在发生的更深层次的事情。拒绝敏感性烦躁不安，以及我们老朋友社交焦虑。所以拒绝，敏感，烦躁，这与我们无法调节我们对感知到的拒绝的情绪反应有关，不是实际的拒绝，而是我们对情况的自已解释。例如，如果有人稍微把身体转开或者离开去洗手间。
at a party whilst they're in conversation with you and five minutes later you see them talking to someone else, you're going to pick up on that. Maybe there is an explanation for why they behave this way, but that is not obvious to you because you are more hypervigilant to the social cues that someone gives off that they are going to reject you. And it also causes us to replay those interactions again and again because what if we missed one of those cues? What if we are blindsided in the future by some memory that we cringe at and that we're not prepared for? What if a small moment or infraction is a symptom to us of some greater social exodus? It's probably not. But this also really links, you know, the relationship between rumination, replaying,
在派对上，当他们正在和你谈话时，五分钟后你看到他们在和别人谈话，你会注意到这一点。也许他们这样表现是有原因的，但这并不是显而易见的，因为你对别人发出的会拒绝你的社交线索更加过度警惕。这也导致我们一遍又一遍地回放这些互动，因为如果我们错过了其中一个线索怎么办？如果我们未来被某个让我们感到畏缩且没有准备好的记忆偷袭了怎么办？如果一个小瞬间或小违规是我们走向更大社交出走的征兆怎么办？可能不是。但这其实也真的将反刍、回放之间的关系联系在了一起，
and social anxiety as well. You know, this is the important thing. You would not be worried about these people if you are not socially in tune with yourself. And I saw this quote from a therapist that I think captures this perfectly. She said, my most anxious patients are often my smartest patients. because that anxiety you are feeling comes from a feeling that you can solve a problem by thinking about it more because you are quite intelligent. And so we spend a lot more time in our own heads. And it's also what makes anxious people such perfectionists because we're used to being able to solve a problem by thinking about it more. Anxiety as we know, it comes in a lot of forms, anything that our brain can find scary or intimidating will cause anxiety, especially for some people, certain or even all social
还有社交焦虑。你知道，这是重要的事情。如果你没有和自己进行社交同步，你就不会担心这些人。我看到了一位治疗师的一句名言，我认为完美地捕捉到了这一点。她说，我最焦虑的患者往往也是最聪明的患者。因为你感到的这种焦虑来自于一种感觉，即你可以通过多思考来解决问题，因为你相当聪明。所以我们在自己的脑海里花了更多的时间。这也是为什么焦虑的人是如此完美的追求者，因为我们习惯了通过多思考来解决问题。众所周知，焦虑有多种形式，任何我们大脑发现可怕或令人生畏的事情都会引起焦虑，特别是对某些人来说，某些甚至所有的社交……
situations. When we are socially anxious, that makes us more alert to our potential flaws or quirks, all the weird things that we say, and it causes us to linger on them for a lot longer because we are terrified of a perceived cost or consequence of being perceived negatively. We see that as a threat. Not only does that lead to a lot of excessive rumination, but potentially even future avoidance of certain situations where we might not know anybody, or we've had a weird experience with someone else who is going, or there'll be big groups of people, because we are so hypervigilant towards those situations as potentially being threatening
情况。当我们感到社交焦虑时，这会让我们更加警惕我们的潜在缺陷或怪癖，我们所说的所有奇怪的话，并导致我们更长时间地纠缠于它们，因为我们害怕被负面看待的潜在成本或后果。我们将其视为威胁。这不仅会导致大量的过度反刍，甚至可能导致未来逃避某些情况，在这些情况中我们可能不认识任何人，或者我们有和其他去的人有奇怪的经历，或者会有大群的人，因为我们对这些情况可能构成威胁高度警惕
to our sense of security and our sense of social acceptance, we just don't go. We avoid them. it's that disproportionate fear of social situations whereby our brain has unintentionally elevated the importance of other people's opinions and judgments such that they become a really deep catalyst for worry, stress, even panic at times. So we replay conversations, I think, as a conclusion because A, it is a way for us to feel secure and to soothe ourselves and be as a way to quote unquote identify our mistakes and correct them
对我们的安全感和社交接受感，我们干脆不去。我们避开它们。这就是对社交情况的不成比例的恐惧，我们的的大脑无意中提高了其他人意见和判断的重要性，以至于它们成为担忧、压力甚至有时恐慌的非常深层的催化剂。因此，我认为我们回放对话，结论是，A，这是我们感到安全和自我安慰的一种方式，B，作为一种“引用”识别我们的错误并纠正它们的方式……
or be vigilant and aware of situations where we may have socially sabotaged ourselves or where people might think that we're weird because we appreciate that the opinions of others matter to us all of this can explain the reasons why some of us find it hard to let go of embarrassing conversations, situations, even years after they happened. It's like a permanent time capsule. I remember one time talking to this person who I had like a massive crush on at university and I had a few glasses of wine and I mispronounced this like one word and then kind of like stumbled over my words. and he laughed and like kind of looked around me to see if anyone else had noticed and still to this
或者对我们可能自我社交破坏或人们可能认为我们很奇怪的情况保持警惕和意识，因为我们很感激别人的意见对我们很重要，所有这一切都可以解释为什么我们中的一些人很难放下尴尬的对话、情况，甚至在它们发生多年后。它就像一个永久的时间胶囊。我记得有一次和这个人说话，我在大学里非常迷恋他，我喝了几杯葡萄酒，我把这个字读错了，然后有点像结巴了。他笑了笑，环顾四周，看看有没有其他人注意到，直到今天……
day I look at that memory and I want to roll into a ball and hide. It is so small. It is such a small moment but sometimes I even intentionally like bring it to mind to see if it still has that same impact and it always does. It's like the feeling of embarrassment has not gone away. It's like a permanent little scar in my mind of that one time five years ago I said one thing weird to this one person. So how do we let go of this need to hold on to these memories, this instinct to keep going over things in the past, conversation, social interactions, whatever they may be? That is what I really want to talk about next. How to stop overthinking your actions. How to stop replaying conversations and letting yourself fall into the mental trap,
今天我看着那段记忆，我只想蜷缩成一团躲起来。它是那么的小。这是一个如此微小的时刻，但有时我甚至故意把它带到脑海中，看看它是否仍然具有相同的冲击力，并且它总是如此。就像尴尬的感觉并没有消失一样。这就像是我脑海中一个永久的小伤疤，五年前我曾对这个人说过一件奇怪的事。那么我们如何放下对这些记忆的执念，放下不断翻阅过去的事情、对话、社交互动无论它们可能是什么的本能呢？这正是我接下来真正想谈的。如何停止过度思考你的行为。如何停止重播对话并让自己陷入精神陷阱，
that these people, their opinion of you matters more than your own and that somehow their judgments of you carry a bigger weight than they actually do. So we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这些人对你的看法比你自己的看法更重要，并且不知何故，他们对你的判断比实际情况更重。因此，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。那是当有自动扶梯可用时走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧不拔的意志、健康体魄以及在这个奇异的现代世界中建立适应力的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难险阻，你将以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。请收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA上双击小肯姆（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you're You can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以……你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克。需要澄清的是，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我愿意在白天谈论快克，但只是想让你们所有人知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你完成那句话。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and comments. conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。欢迎在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验和评论。与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我在说。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person
我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得做一个好人很重要……
while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her.
当你在地球上的时候？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的意图。兄弟。绝对的。这是两个不同的信任级别。我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是基尔·盖恩斯，我们一起畅谈治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法院听证会暴露了她……
story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapp. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
故事中的巨大矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。埃伦女士，你两次篡改了这特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑爆炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Spending so much time in our brains and thought patterns and spirals that we don't want to be having, can be really exhausting to say the very least, especially when we feel like we have no control over the contents of these memories. Such is always the case with things that happened in the past. So let's break down what we can do to change this by kind of stripping back the rumination process. Firstly, put things into perspective by leaning into the what if.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。将如此多的时间花在我们的大脑、思维模式和漩涡中，这是我们不想拥有的，至少可以说会非常令人筋疲力尽，特别是当我们觉得我们对这些记忆的内容毫无控制力时。过去发生的事情总是如此。因此，让我们通过剥离反刍过程来剖析我们能做些什么来改变这一点。首先，通过倾向于“如果……会怎样”来把事情放在正确的视角。
The easiest way to identify whether a thought is a product of our anxiety or if it is real is if the thought starts with what if. And when we replay conversations, the what if is often, what if this person doesn't like me? What if they thought I was awkward? What if I said something weird? Instead of trying to work through that thought spiral by getting stuck in the worst case scenario, follow that scenario through to its end with me. what if they don't like me well then they may not want to be my friend or spend time with me okay so what if they don't want to spend time with me well then i'll feel isolated and alone what if i feel isolated
判断一个想法是焦虑的产物还是真实的，最简单的方法就是看这个想法是否以“如果……会怎样”开头。当我们回放对话时，“如果……会怎样”通常是，如果这个人不喜欢我怎么办？如果他们认为我很尴尬怎么办？如果我说了什么奇怪的话怎么办？与其陷入最坏的情况，试图通过克服那个思想漩涡来解决问题，不如和我一起把那个场景推演到最后。如果他们不喜欢我，那他们可能不想和我做朋友或共度时光。好吧，如果他们不想共度时光，那我会感到孤立和孤独。如果我感到孤立和孤独怎么办？
and alone well then i'll feel bad what if i feel bad what next well when you challenge that thought you find the baseline feeling that you actually are worried about in this situation it's not that you're worried about this person's opinion, it's that you're worried about what their opinion might cause for you, which is loneliness, which is rejection, which is feeling isolated. So instead of working towards fixing your kind of tendency to replay conversations, work towards increasing your confidence around your value and your enjoyment of your own company and, you know, really strengthening the friendships and your appreciation of the friendships and relationships that will be there regardless of what you said in this one conversation one time.
孤独怎么办，那我会觉得不好。如果我感觉不好，接下来呢？当你挑战这个想法时，你会发现你在这种情况真正担心的基准感觉。你担心的不是这个人的看法，而是担心他们的看法可能会给你带来的影响，也就是孤独，也就是被拒绝，也就是感到孤立。因此，与其致力于修复你反复回放对话的倾向，不如致力于增强你对自己的价值、享受自己公司乐趣的信心，以及（你知道的）真正加强友谊，以及对那些无论你在这次对话中说了什么都会一如既往存在的友谊和关系的感激之情。
Talking about our what ifs and taking them to what I call their natural conclusion also just shows us how irrational so many of our fears are. Is it really the case that one thing you've said in a conversation or one weird social interaction is going to ruin you, is going to bring down your entire life? Have you ever seen that happen to someone before? And I'm not talking about people who choose to be really racist or sexist or homophobic, but people who maybe just laughed at the wrong time or revealed maybe a little bit too much. These people, their lives are not ruined because they said one weird thing one time.
谈论我们的“如果……会怎样”，并将它们带到我所谓的自然结论，也向我们展示了我们有多少恐惧是多么不理性。真的是这样吗，你在对话中所说的一句话或一个奇怪的社交互动会毁了你，会毁掉你的整个生活？你以前见过这种事发生在别人身上吗？我不是指那些选择种族主义、性别歧视或恐同的人，而是指那些可能只是在错误时间笑了一下或者可能透露太多的人。这些人并没有因为说了一句奇怪的话而毁了他们的生活。
But our brains do like to catastrophize and overthink, you know, what of where the first one, who that happens to. Like I said, it is a way of problem solving. So it's looking for the worst case scenario to prepare yourself, despite the chances of that happening. being very low. So it's important to realize that your appraisal of a situation, what you think this person might think about you is, A, probably incorrect and be very irrational. We also need to shift our attention, our behavioral intention, from valuing what other people may think of us to valuing our own authenticity and peace. Behavioral intentions are so powerful for changing a number of behaviors from things like diet to exercise habits, how we treat others, and also how we treat
但我们的大脑确实喜欢把事情灾难化，并过度思考“如果”我们是第一个发生这种情况的人。就像我说的，这是一种解决问题的方式。所以它在寻找最坏的情况来为自己做准备，尽管这种情况发生的几率非常低。因此，重要的是要认识到你对情况的评估，你认为这个人可能对你的看法，A，可能是错误的，B是非常不理性的。我们还需要将我们的注意力、我们的行为意图从重视别人对我们的看法转移到重视我们自己的真实和内心的平静。行为意图对于改变一系列行为非常强大，从饮食、运动习惯等事情，到我们如何对待他人，以及我们如何对待……
ourselves. Before going into a situation that you know might cause you to ruminate after the fact or could be stressful, set a behavioral intention there. I am going to let myself behave as I would like. I'm not going to worry about other people. I'm going to say what's on my mind without feeling embarrassed by it. I think it's important to set a behavioral intention with yourself because it reinforces this kind of your authenticity firstly, but this positive belief that you're actually in control of a situation and you are in control of whether you choose to behave in a way that is true to yourself or in a way that is attempting to make others like you. Literally, you can talk to yourself and say, I can choose to think about this,
我们自已。在进入一个你知道事后可能会让你反刍或可能有压力的情境之前，在那里设定一个行为意图。我将让自己按照我喜欢的方式行事。我不会担心别人。我会说出我心里想的话，而不会为此感到尴尬。我认为给自己设定一个行为意图很重要，因为它首先强化了你的真实性，其次强化了这样一种积极的信念：你实际上掌控着情况，你掌控着自已是选择以真实自我的方式行事，还是以试图迎合他人喜欢的方式行事。从字面上讲，你可以自言自语并说：我可以选择去想这件事，
I can choose to replay this conversation, or I can spend my time on something more valuable. Which do I choose? And then rationalize the urge to choose, you know, the replaying conversation option. I know that I'm only doing this because I'm overthinking, and because of my social hypervigilance, not because of anything that actually happened. I know that if I choose to replay this conversation, it won't actually change anything about what was said. it won't change a single thing and even at the end of the day
我可以选择重播这段对话，或者我可以把时间花在更有价值的事情上。我选哪个？然后合理化选择“重播对话”选项的冲动。我知道我这样做只是因为我过度思考，因为我的社交过度警惕，而不是因为实际发生了什么。我知道如果我选择重播这段对话，它并不会真正改变所说过的话的任何事情。它不会改变哪怕一件事，而且到头来……
if it could it doesn't really matter if this person chooses to think of me some way that is not my business that is nothing to do with me unless they choose to bring it up allow yourself to be emotionally detached from what other people think about you
如果它能，其实也无所谓，如果这个人选择以某种方式看待我，那不管我的事，那跟我没有任何关系，除非他们选择提出来。让自己在情感上脱离别人对你的看法。
you're not invested in that you can also channel that that urge because I know it is quite a powerful urge Sometimes it's not easy to counteract, but instead of suppressing it, you can also channel it into more positive outlets. Like discussing it with your friend or your boyfriend, whoever is removed from the situation might be able to provide you with a rational voice when you can't. Finally, we can process our need to replay conversations by taking ourselves out of our minds and into our bodies. channeling that nervous, contemplative energy into a different source. Our anxiety is just as physical as it is mental.
你并没有投入其中，你还可以引导这种冲动，因为我知道这确实是一种非常强大的冲动。有时它并不容易抵制，但与其压抑它，你也可以把它引导到更积极的出口。比如和你的朋友或男朋友讨论，任何不局限于这种情况的人可能都能够在无法自拔时为你提供一个理性的声音。最后，我们可以通过将自已从思维中抽离并进入身体，来处理我们反复播放对话的需求。将那种紧张的、沉思的能量引导到不同的来源。我们的焦虑既是身体上的，也是精神上的。
It manifests in restlessness, fast breathing, headaches being stick to your stomach. And that all exacerbates our sense of emotional stress. So it's kind of like this ongoing circle or cycle. How we can interrupt that is provide these anxious thoughts with an outlet by activating what is known as our skeletal muscle brain axis. through tensing or contracting and then releasing our muscles. So start from your calves all the way to your neck, tense your muscles, release them.
它表现为坐立不安、呼吸急促、头痛、胃紧缩。这一切都加剧了我们的情绪压力。所以这有点像一个正在进行的圆圈或循环。我们如何打断这种循环是通过激活所谓的骨骼肌脑轴，为这些焦虑的想法提供一个出口。通过紧张或收缩然后放松我们的肌肉。所以从你的小腿一直到脖子，绷紧你的肌肉，然后放松它们。
By doing that, you're releasing a lot of that mental anguish as well. And there are so many studies that demonstrate the effect this has on relieving our spiraling or persistent thoughts or just anxiety in general. We can also participate in, obviously, sports, go to the gym, exercise, particularly activities that give you a sense of moving forward, not in a symbolic or a spiritual way, but literally just physically moving forward. When we engage in these kinds of exercise, what we're actually engaging in is this thing called
通过这样做，你也在释放大量的精神痛苦。有这么多的研究证明了这种方法对缓解我们盘旋的、持续的想法或单纯的焦虑的效果。我们还可以参与（很明显）运动、去健身房、锻炼，特别是那些给你前进感觉的活动，不是以一种象征性的或精神上的方式，而是字面上的身体向前移动。当我们参与这些锻炼时，我们实际上参与的是被称为……的事情。
lateral eye movement. Basically to break this down, anxiety, and when we replay on conversations, that is anxiety. It is a fear response that has evolved to help us confront danger. And the way that we did this in the past, and still to this day, is either by fighting back or fleeing, by running away. And when we did this, all of that adrenaline that was initially pumped into our body has a place to go. We begin to feel calmer. We begin to feel more focused. We feel like we're doing something about the problem by either fighting back or fleeing.
横向眼球运动。基本上来剖析一下，焦虑，以及当我们回放对话时，那就是焦虑。这是一种为了帮助我们面对危险而进化出来的恐惧反应。而我们在过去以及直到今天做到这一点的方式，要么是反击，要么是逃跑，通过逃跑。当我们这样做时，最初注入我们身体的所有肾上腺素就有了一个去处。我们开始感到平静。我们开始感到更加专注。我们觉得通过反击或逃跑，我们在针对问题做些什么。
you can replicate that feeling of being active in the face of danger when you go for a run or a walk or a cycle, that forward movement makes you feel like you're escaping a threat. So in this case, that might be someone's potential negative judgments. You can take that anxiety and feel like you are progressing past it by physically moving forward. And the exercise in itself also allows a lot of that adrenaline, that cortisol, just that stress to be kind of expelled from your body. I know it sounds really strange, but it really does work. Next time you're sitting there being like, oh my gosh, what does this person think of me?
当你去跑步、散步或骑自行车时，你可以复制这种在危险面前保持活跃的感觉，这种向前的运动让你觉得你在逃避威胁。所以在这种情况下，那可能是别人潜在的消极判断。你可以带走那种焦虑，并通过身体向前移动，感觉自己正在超越它。锻炼本身也允许大量的肾上腺素、皮质醇以及那种压力从你的身体中排出。我知道这听起来很奇怪，但它确实管用。下次你坐在那里想：“天哪，这个人是怎么看我的？”
I'm going to be fired. I'm going to lose my job. This person's never going to speak to me again. I know it sounds so silly, but go for a run. And you'll feel that a lot of the anxiety in that moment will definitely dissipate for you. Here is your final reminder to give yourself a little bit of a reality check here. I say it all the time, but no one is looking at you as closely as you are looking at yourself. Can you remember the last time you thought about something someone had said and judged them for it permanently?
我要被解雇了。我要失去工作了。这个人再也不会跟我说话了。我知道这听起来很傻，但去跑跑步吧。你会觉得那一刻的许多焦虑感绝对会烟消云散。这是对你的最后提醒，让你在这里清醒一下认识现实。我经常这样说，但没有人像你自己那样密切地关注你。你还记得上一次你想到别人说过的话并永远评判他们是什么时候吗？
And can you remember exactly what they said? How did that change the relationship? What did it really mean for you? You probably can't remember that level of detail, just as someone else can't remember. remember that level of detail about the conversation that you just had with them. Try and replay your last conversation that you had with, I don't know, your co-worker or your friend. Replay every single moment in your head right now. And I know that sounds counterintuitive, but when you start to do that, you realize that there is a lot of things that you can't really recall. And the same goes for
你还记得他们具体说了什么吗？这如何改变了这段关系？这对你来说到底意味着什么？你可能记不得那么细致的细节了，正如别人也记不得你刚刚跟他们进行的对话中那些细致的细节一样。试着回放你上一次与我不知道是谁、你的同事或你的朋友进行的对话。现在在脑海中重播每一个瞬间。我知道这听起来违反直觉，但当你开始这样做时，你会意识到有很多事情你其实记不清了。同样的情况也适用于
the other person. Our brain wants to pay really great attention to our own actions and feelings rather than others. And the same goes for the person that you are talking to. Most of the time we are quite inward focused. And when it comes to replaying conversations, recognizing that fact is something that can actually help put things into perspective. No one is ever really that focused on you, and that is quite liberating.
另一个人。我们的大脑更愿意密切关注我们自己的行为和感受，而不是别人的感受。你交谈的那个人也是如此。大多数时候，我们的注意力都是向内的。当涉及到重播对话时，认识到这一事实实际上有助于把事情看清楚。从来没有人真正那么关注你，这相当令人解脱。
It's freeing. And it takes time to really embrace that, but the outcome of recognizing that you really are just, a lot more critical than you need to be, is that you release yourself from that spiral and from that social examination. Furthermore, even if you did something weird or you did something off, so what? Human's memory, our memory is so fallible. It doesn't last as long as we think it does. And like most things, that embarrassment is temporary. It's like a small scab that may take a while to heal but it will eventually. And to get really existential, the world is so large. There are so many people
这令人感到自由。真正接受这一点需要时间，但认识到自己其实只是比必要时更加批判的结局是，你将自己从那种不断盘旋的想法和社交审视中解放出来了。此外，即使你做了什么奇怪的事或表现得有些不对劲，那又怎样？人类的记忆，我们的记忆是如此不可靠。它持续的时间没有我们想象的那么长。像大多数事情一样，那种尴尬只是暂时的。它就像一个小伤疤，可能需要一段时间才能愈合，但最终会好的。往大里说，世界是如此之大。有那么多的人
living their own independent lives. There's like billions of other people on this planet. And we're really only here for a short time. That conversation you had, that weird thing you said, is such a small moment in comparison to not just like the length of your life and how much you will do, but just in terms of the world and everything else that's going on, you don't need to worry. Everything is temporary. This feeling of embarrassment of cringe, of awkwardness is temporary. You will move past it. And I promise you that most people probably don't even remember the thing that you spend hours worrying about. So for all of my fellow people who love the conversational replay, I really hope that this episode has helped you out. I know I gave a lot of advice here, but I will say I still
过着他们独立的生活。这个星球上有几十亿其他人。我们来到这里的时间真的很短。你进行的那次对话、你说的那件奇怪的事，与不仅是你的寿命以及你将要做的事情的长度相比，仅仅是微不足道的瞬间，而且就世界和正在发生的其他一切而言，你不需要担心。一切都是暂时的。这种尴尬、难为情、局促不安的感觉是暂时的。你会走出来的。我向你保证，大多数人可能根本不记得你花了好几个小时担忧的事情。所以，对于所有喜欢回放对话的朋友们，我真心希望这一集能对你们有所帮助。我知道我在这里给了很多建议，但我必须说我依然
do struggle with this. I think if you're naturally like also an empath, you're naturally very like socially aware or socially conscious, self-conscious more like it, it's really hard to break that habit because you have spent so many years of your life learning to prioritize other people's opinions. So I hope that this is just one small step to kind of greater mental freedom when it comes to this rumination pattern. I hope it gave you some practical tips to help you out. I'm going to say again, thank you to Abby, who provided this episode suggestion. If you have an episode suggestion, please feel free to message me at that psychology podcast. We love getting some feedback. We love getting some suggestions, some inspiration, some motivation. And if you enjoyed this episode,
在与此作斗争。我想如果你天生也是一个共情能力强的人，你天生就会非常关注社交，或者说有社交意识、更加自我意识过剩，要打破这个习惯真的很难，因为你花了很多年的时间来学习如何优先考虑别人的意见。所以我希望这只是朝着这种反刍思维模式带来的更大心理自由迈出的小小一步。我希望它能给你提供一些实用的小贴士来帮助你。我要再次感谢阿比（Abby），她提供了这一集的建议。如果你有任何节目建议，请随时通过那个心理学播客给我发信息。我们喜欢听取反馈。我们喜欢听取一些建议、一些灵感、一些动力。如果你喜欢这一集，
please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. And follow along. There are some really good episodes coming out. I don't want to given away, but December is going to be a killer month for the podcast. So make sure that you're here for it. And we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. And you will call.
请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。并关注我们。有一些非常精彩的节目即将推出。我不想剧透，但12月将是播客表现强劲的一个月。所以请确保你准时收听。我们下周将带着另一集回归。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦。
out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
你将迎难而上，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。也就是在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“TWO%”。在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和萨姆·J（Sam J.）以及亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）来说都是一个重大时刻，1984年对我来说意义重大。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill. on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
在每一集中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）。回顾80年代。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。
podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着西装，就像穿着盔甲一样。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要——
listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。在2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。“埃伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我伪造了一次测试。”这需要一支网络侦探大队才能揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Alespian and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
格雷格·阿莱斯平（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。